YEN-JIE LEE: I think
chalkboard is much more
natural for the
students and for me
because if I write all the
equations on the slides, first
of all, all those equations
appear at the same time.
And so it is actually
harder for the student
to follow the logic
between formulas.
And my feeling is that
it is so much naturaler
to see all those
equations popping up
in a logical sequence for them.
And by writing down
them on the chalkboard,
people have time to
think as well, what
is actually happening.
And I have also the freedom to
point to the relevant equation
on the board slowly so
that people, everybody
who is not very familiar with
the mathematics can follow.
Factorial x squared,
plus V triple prime 0
divided by 3 factorial x to
the third, plus infinite number
of times.
And the V(0) is the position
of where you have minimum.
So I think that's
actually a decision
to use chalkboard in
combination with slides.
Usually, my slides
contain information
which is actually
already covered
from the previous lecture.
So that serves a purpose to
flash through the information
which is actually
already covered
duirng the last few lectures,
to remind people that, OK, you
have learned this before.
Right?
And so I don't have
to waste a lot of time
to copy them on the chalkboard
because they already
learned that.
And secondly, I can use slides
to include interesting figures,
interesting videos, interesting
pictures, et cetera,
so that it should be that is
complementary to my chalkboard
teaching style.